[Music]
hello guys welcome to a very special
ichi live we are here to break down all
things Celebrity Big Brother with Queen
of BiBi I'm Bryce and er I'm Katie
Krauss and should we just get right into
it
yes you've already been in that house
you were there day one premiere episode
I think we have some b-roll you are
number season so far I mean you've been
watching you've been in the house it is
so good it is so refreshing
yeah to see a big brother season where
everyone's playing the game I am so
excited that they are going in they're
going hard yeah they're all playing the
game they are all going for it they're
all like seeming like they really kind
of know what's going on and they want to
be there and I love that I love that
we're watching them play I love that
we're watching them live just everything
about this season has been epic yeah
were you guys watching make sure that
you're sending in your questions your
comments we're gonna take them right
here on this lovely iPad and you're
gonna answer them all
this season is moving so fast we're
basically getting two weeks of Big
Brother every week what do you make of
this very fast for me I played for 76
days and I think yeah twice I know it's
crazy so I think it's so different to
see a season where they're playing such
a quick game and I see people like
Shannon I think they're really playing
this quick game but then you have
someone like Ross oh I think it knows
it's a quick game but is actually like
holding it back a little bit he's
playing a little bit of a safer game I
guess okay you still have to play Big
Brother because there's still people
there getting evicted you know hey it's
twice a week yes but it's still gonna be
that like marathon you know big brother
we say is a marathon not a sprint and I
should like Lord it is a marathon cuz
you're just you know in there's so much
dead time they have less dead time
however they're still like with Shannon
16 letter word I think that was a little
too hard yeah I think it put a big
target yeah
it's the balance is a little off
Shannon's playing so hard so fast and
some people aren't playing hard enough
yeah exactly and I I loved watching that
and I love watching Shannon play so hard
because as a fan I love the
competitiveness I love watching players
that are like going in there and they're
going for it but then there's also that
balance between like girlfriend you're
not on the block like you just won the
HOH let's calm down yeah I say that cuz
I did that my first season and I had to
change it for when I went back and won
right I would have never won season 12
the way I was playing but when I went
back for season 13 I knew I had to be
more of that marathon player more of the
making alliances making the friends not
being the big threat you know right yeah
we were saying that we were seeing
shades of you in Shannon's games 100%
I knew this if you don't want to know
but Shannon and James are currently on
the block because Arianda is HOH and has
put them up what do you make of that are
you upset so upset I'm really upset that
the girls Alliance didn't work out I'm
really upset that this was something
that they couldn't do because there's no
showmance as this season what are you
gonna think I don't get it let's get
into that because we actually have the
girls Lions kind of blew up when they
got Chuck out and they slightly
flip-flopped on that decision there's
him leaving he was blindsided I talked
to him right after this happened he
called it so crappy he said the night
before he was safe woke up the next
morning and no one could know he knew so
he knew that day and then when they all
the next week or next week next time
when they were playing for was it POV or
HOH that was Bowl arena Oh HOH yep and
this Omarosa moment happened that was
like wow we're just scorched earth
policy yeah check this out
sit around oh we can talk our strategy
why would she why would Shanon so loudly
say that knowing that Omarosa was right
there I kind of feel like that was a big
turning point for how things a turning
point and I think it was really really
stupid of you know Shannon yeah and I
think she wasn't thinking like in the
moment you're thinking okay this is the
game play because I Marissa is coming
after me after our alliance but then you
can't tell people that like you have to
say it in a closed door you have to say
it in private I think that for Omarosa
to hear that like man that the claws are
gonna come out for sure that's also so
strange because that wasn't true Shannon
hate him it's like paranoid big brother
States so fast you thought this was true
when really Keisha and Omarosa had just
been like hanging out with Chuck they
weren't making an alliance no deals were
made nothing I think that for that you
just getting in that house it just
changes your mindset to where you almost
think that everyone's coming after you
all the time and if they're not talking
to you they're obviously talking about
you you just think that so I think
Shannon has gotten into the Big Brother
mentality where she probably thinks
everyone's coming after her being on the
block's not gonna help it if she doesn't
win POV she's probably gonna go home but
I think like in these situations
especially if you're a Shannon you have
to be really careful with how you say
things like instead of thing go after a
Moroso she should have just been like
let's all split it up let's all play
fair you know what I mean like right
never hasn't gone like she just needs to
be a little more political about sure as
someone who has won the game and played
twice is it super infuriating to watch
and see these mistakes play out are you
and Brendan like screaming or watching
really screaming at our televisions we
are just so frustrated watching the
mistakes getting played out and it's
also a point where you're just like I
know that they know better than that yes
they went in and she was like this is
how I'm gonna play I'm gonna go in the
dye room and tell you guys what I'm
doing I'm gonna be in the house be
everyone's best friend so you know that
like her gameplay has just changed and
she's not thinking and I'm a huge fan of
her because she's a competitive female
but it's just like I watch her make the
same mistakes I made so I literally am
screaming at my TV every single week
yeah she told us once she was gonna go
in the house she was like I'm gonna
treat as an acting role play a part and
she did it she just is that it just
really switches like something in your
brain you get in there and you're just
like yeah I think so and I think that
the fact that they made that girl's
Alliance before the first HOH I think
that that really kind of put a you know
that mentality into her head because I
think she thought okay I have to win for
the girls Alliance I have to do this I
have to do that now she's in charge of
the first HOH so she's gaining the power
and she's getting the blood on her hands
and she's the one that they're like
targeting James for you know so I
believe that in her mind she's feeling
that fight-or-flight yeah that really
like if I don't do this I'm gonna get
kicked out of the house yeah we want to
talk Omarosa but so many questions
coming in yes let's get to one or two of
these right now
Alissa wants to know who do you think is
playing the best game had to call it if
I was gonna call it the best game right
now is Ross and Melissa but I or Martha
but I really think that Marissa is
playing a better game because to be
completely honest like she's everyone's
best friend and everyone lost her she's
so funny she's fun you know like you
know she was competitive but like she
hasn't won anything yet so you're not
threatened by her right I almost think
she's playing the best game because
she's kind of everybody's friend right
now yeah what do you make of her cuz she
did actually win that meet oh right that
ended up sending Keisha home do you
think she should have won because if she
didn't then the nominations could have
stayed the same I was thinking about
that well this is the thing it's kind of
a veto that didn't matter because
everyone is I think everyone knew they
were gonna send Keisha home yeah that
was the discussion so because that was
the discussion it was kind of one of
those vetoes where it's like Oh win keep
the noms the same yeah she's going home
you know it's one of those things where
you it's like a safe veto to win so
maybe that she's doing that so that in
the end she'll have that checkmark like
I her name exactly I did win when I
needed to because I think it's smart of
her to actually win something like that
I'd another thing if she wins HOH in
sends Mehta home that's another one
that's pretty safe for her you know I
can see her doing that
okay let's talk about Omarosa she played
in the HOH comp lost to Marissa and then
just immediately stepped out of the
backyard into the house and went banging
on the door which I don't know if you
have an asthma attack I don't think you
can
Huff your way across the house bang on
the door and scream medic yeah did you
think that was real or did you think
that was I thought that was Omarosa
being a Moroso like Comoros oh we know
you're know like we get you we've
watched you so I think that for her that
was her almost throwing a fit slash
trying to spin it around so that
everyone feels bad for her because you
guys remember in Celebrity Apprentice
when she got injured that was the thing
for like the rest of the season yeah
it's her playbook her reality TV blind
playbook and she knows how to play
reality TV she's amazing here's a great
moment of reality to be from Omarosa
watch this
it was a really rough night I was
admitted to the hospital but we were
able to get it my asthma under control
this was a really scary experience thank
God I am back in the game
[Music]
she so eloquently that you almost she's
so convincing she makes it sound so much
more severe than it actually is I think
she went in with the role to play like
she took that as an acting role because
girlfriend she is like going for it I
mean she even does the comic off like
she's remembering she has to COFF
because she has ass right we all should
feel bad for her and she sneaks in so
nobody know she's there she just want to
make a big scene
it wasn't until like I think four people
went in and saw she was there and then
like Mariana was like she's like she
didn't even want to tell anyone she came
back cuz she wanted it to be like the
drama do you think that helped her case
because now she's seemingly safe and
appears a little weaker almost I think
the drama helps Tom roses case because
why would you get her out when you know
you're gonna get her out that's exactly
what's the point I mean we're always
gonna have an Omarosa target like let's
go after a Shannon or James you know
when they might be harder to get out but
I'm a row so why would we get hurt right
she's that like good medium target where
it's like she's always gonna have a
target on her back
get her out when it's right not when you
just not the best competitor and we
always see what kind of drama is gonna
unfold
I bet the houseguests want to see what
kind of drama amuro's right you know
she's just cuz I want to see that no I
think there's a chance if she wins the
veto that she would stay and I think
there's even a chance for them to spin
it to get James out just by the dialog
that's been going on in the live feeds
I'm thinking that there is a chance they
could get one of them to win the veto
and keep the other one in the house but
it's gonna be really tight it's gonna be
like a Metta World Peace situation where
yeah he's gonna be like alright just
vote me out alive Peter oh my I'm like
the biggest live feeder it's
embarrassing Brendan and I have it on
24/7 in the background it's ridiculous
we cannot get enough of it yeah I'm
Brendan will be at he works at UCLA so
he'll be at UCLA he'll call me and have
an exclusive clip from the live feeds
that isn't out there yet then we're
gonna talk about that's good and this
live feeds has been so entertaining you
guys if you're not watching like
honestly you're missing out because it's
good right is hilarious she's all access
you go sign up and you get access to all
the other big brothers yeah so you can
go back and watch these in 12 and 13
Benjamin alright more fan comments
coming in Sarah says Shannon is the
bigger threat than James hope she goes
Omarosa needs to go to there's one up
here that I wanted to jana says how do
you think it will work that the jury
isn't sequestered i think that's a
really interesting question because it's
gonna be like the first few seasons
before season 3 when they weren't
sequestered however it's not as long as
if season and everyone kind of knows
each other so they're not gonna go in
the diary room we haven't seen them
going in there yet talking you know game
to each other or like against each other
right they're not like ah she's stupid
so i'm thinking that it's gonna be okay
and they're really smart especially like
I watch Ross you know he's so smart in
there he's like she's lovely
oh we know we just want to make sure
she's okay so I think that they know
they're playing the jury too which is
really smart
it's also like in a normal season a Big
Brother you have 75 to 90 days to get to
meet somebody you learn them really get
to know them in this short amount of
time those episodes and those diary
moments can actually maybe help inform
your decision at the end a hundred
percent I really think that's true I
think it's gonna help him form the
decisions I also think they're going
we're gonna come out and see the results
of the whoever wins it's gonna be
because of who the people like the most
right yeah so when Keisha went home she
dropped this bombshell about Shannon do
you think that that affected Shannon's
gameplay and for those of you out there
who haven't seen it let's roll that clip
into James I want you to know that I
have nothing to hide and nothing to
conceal I did the dirty work of Shannon
you were not my choice well you were our
choice let me be honest you were our
choice however know that this is not an
alliance just know that and I just hope
and wish you all the best and you know
play this game and go hard
she and my in our post eviction chat she
called that her ammunition she was
giving them they have the gun she was
giving them the ammunition to load into
it do you think she's gonna put her foot
in her mouth when she goes back and
I think it was a great big brother move
great entertainment but not smart
because there's no reason for her to
call out Shannon it was in her Alliance
originally and why is she trying to
break up Shannon and James like they're
not gonna be swayed at this point by
Keyshia or anything I morosa says for
that matter right I think they're two
like smart and I think they're already a
twosome you know what I mean I've
noticed that people are playing in pairs
in the house right now and it's really
interesting to see two because the only
people we have that don't have a pair
are meta and Mark so I think that's so
true I wish that they would try and
recruit them to create a new the
smartest thing to do this week would be
for Omarosa to grab Shannon and James
and just be like listen this is it we
need to grab a crew grab mark grab meta
and like they'll have the votes and go
against Ross Marissa Brandi and Ari and
I mean I know that Ari's in power so
it's a little bit more difficult right
now but if they don't do that right
they'll get the votes and if they don't
do it they're gonna really have a
problem because they're the four of them
earning now that's not you're the queen
can you see the things that we don't
call that meta isn't a pair moving on to
live feeds we have a very funny
exclusive clip here from the live feeds
that it's just like it just shows you
how anything can get anyone excited in
this house because all you have to
entertain yourselves is each other
[Laughter]
season what was like that moment for you
guys like you got something awesome
you're like oh my god camera when we get
to take our own pictures the camera
every week you're like throwing a party
because it's Friday there's a camera
coming you're so excited
I mean honestly when we have to clean
like nobody wants to clean but you are
excited to have something to do you so
much downtime and I think people
understand how dirty that house gets I
mean there's been an
and problem multiple times on perhaps
the cockroach problem isn't really that
exciting to get a vacuum invited clean
okay I think we don't clean because
we're just like Oh clean it later
om said you get into this mentality of
time and thank you so much I'll just
we'll do my dishes tonight you know like
I remember I was like I'm gonna be on a
schedule this season on season 13 I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna wake up I'm
gonna work out and then you get wake up
and you're like I'm have some coffee and
sit yeah and then it's noon and you're
like what did I even brush my teeth yeah
whatever it's interesting to you because
Ross's reaction getting the vacuum is
even him playing the game like oh my god
it's so exciting and I think from
Marissa it was genuine yeah I think for
him it was him playing the game the live
feeds bring us funny moments like that
but they also bring ass drama that's not
seen on TV and there's this whole story
that hasn't really been explored on the
show but I loved it of Brandis maybe
partying a little more than we're seeing
so this is from I think the first night
of the girls talking about the brandy
we're talking about brandy no she just
she just say well they hate you anyway
they hate you anyway brandy said it to
me
who said that Brandi said it to me okay
about them they hate you anyway they're
sending you home anyway so why can't I
say brandy said it to me about the guys
so I walked by Cameron said Simon I'll
talk to you soon I'll be calling you
next week all right so basically the
back story is that first thing they had
a lot of alcohol which is usually kind
of not given to the BB House again ever
but they had a lot maybe brandy pulled
out her old Real Housewives tricks and
was saying a lot of stuff to a lot of
people a lot of yeah she was saying a
lot more than a lot of stuff she was
telling them who's gonna go after who
like what that she thinks about them
which she is the only person in that
house who has played Big Brother before
but the virgin how do you think having
alcohol at your fingertips this season
is affecting the game is it nice to have
is it I'm jealous
I think it would have taken so much
pressure off of me we got like at I
don't know eight o'clock at night we
would get like one bottle of wine for
ten people so it was like one glass and
we would fight over it yeah and so this
year they're getting like all this
alcohol like they have whatever they
want yeah
so I think it's fun for them because
they get to be more like loose and more
themselves they probably forget more
about the cameras you know I think so
it's great I mean give them more it's
funny you bring that up though because I
remember very vividly a season where
people actually are fighting over yeah
like they're hiding it and being like
where'd you put the bottle of wine like
with Jessa no we used to hide beers in
the HOH like refrigerator so that nobody
would take them so we could have them
the next week oh yeah people will do for
alcohol your guys is a commentary Z says
Shannon James and Metta all the way
that's gonna be interesting we're gonna
play a little bit of my interview with
Kisha after this where she also talks
about Metta Stacy says love Ross and
Marissa and let's see here Cheryl Oh
she'll just wants to check in on you how
was your baby you can follow me on all
this social media like for adores stuff
[ __ ] I post pictures all the time are
you thinking more babies so right I'd
like about two years you do start
thinking about more babies and I think
we've really really want another one
it's just kind of this timing right now
Brendan's doing a postdoc so we're like
should we wait here should we go for it
now because then we'll have a baby in a
year so it's kind of all up in the air
but definitely another one what do you
do if your child grows up and is like
mom I want to go on Big Brother I'm
training her now er do you want a
gingerbread competition at this
Christmas oh yeah we're like already
doing all the climbing with her every
day I'm like adora you're gonna win big
brother one day all right
so ET is your home to exclusive Big
Brother content for Celebrity Big
Brother so for the next like couple of
weeks
we're getting the only exit interviews
right after they talked to Julie yeah
and we're saving some fun stuff for
these live chats we're doing including
this Fast Five with Keisha
Chuck's is just went live on et online
but check out everything Keisha had to
say
out her time in the BB house fiction
Fast Five okay who will win this show I
think meadow could win he slept the
whole season he slept the whole time and
he's completely under the people
everyone's radar and I'm like he's the
champion don't be deceived by meta is
sleeping and being silly maybe it's a
whole cover-up for hate I think that
they're sadly mistaken if they
underestimate him all right who is the
worst houseguest you know I'm not gonna
say that about anybody I feel like
everyone has their idiosyncrasies
everyone has their quirks but that's
also part of the fun of it like we had a
lot of fun with like mark does this like
shuffle thing but I made fun of a lot of
time but it was all in love and in humor
well yeah we saw you leave that house
and you kind of said everybody I want
everybody's information yes who is your
friend for life out of this game
do you know what crazy probably Omarosa
I told her she's not gonna be able to
get rid of it now but there are plenty
of people Marissa was very sweet as well
as Ross and you know there's so many
like I promise you it sounds crazy but I
feel like I will have a very special
connection with each and every
houseguest because we shared such a
unique experience and I took something
from each one of the nut took but they
taught me something every last person in
that house taught me something and I'm
very appreciative to have had the
journey with them yeah only you guys
have been through this oh and we're the
first so no one else is gonna be able to
really comprehend and I'm really excited
we've already talked about like our
group chats and all of that and I just
can't wait to you know just continue you
bond and build the relationships with
everybody all right now what is the
strangest thing you saw in that house
there were so many odd things I mean we
did a whole telenovela skit on a wreck
like we we entertained ourselves
thoroughly the phone call things we
would do we just always had fun and do
you appreciate that
like we literally like there were on the
floor there were different kind of color
squares and we made up our own what is
that game what is it call that you put
your hand on the twister twister we made
our own twister in the Big Brother house
and it
so much fun so we just made up all kind
of games you guys are very innovative
all right and if you had to boil down
your Big Brother experience into one
word what would that one word be unique
very unique unique so my takeaway from
that she says meta yes you got player
and she did say he's a champion I mean
in basketball maybe don't count him out
yet but I disagree with I think he's
gonna just go home just because he's
like I want to go home yeah he'll be an
easy and easy get out get out for sure I
think I think Marissa in my book I think
Marissa wins the whole thing yeah we
wanted to ask you there's a lot of
rumors speculation out there about
season 20 potentially being an all-star
season I haven't died Dan Kiessling has
told me he thinks you should play again
Janice told me she wants to see you play
again I thought you guys were talking
about watching it it would be amazing to
watch would you go back in and play an
all-star season again I mean I would
love to go back and play an all-star
season you guys I love Big Brother I
don't really have anything to prove but
I would love to just be in there with
all these newer houseguests and be like
you guys like maybe coach them or
something but I don't know I mean it's
hard with the baby but I would love to I
would love to watch an all-star season
who would you want to play with if you
could pick three how scary so Vanessa
for a hundred percent my sister
obviously yeah um cuz I never played
with her and then I think maybe like a
Paul and I would love to see Paul in a
third time go ahead and hate haters but
I would love to watch Paul on one more
time and I think he could pull out the
win I mean third time's the charm right
I would love to see a Rachel and Paul
align like a friendship Elena Millea
maybe I don't know seriously though I
would love to watch that all right I
think we're players we're gonna wrap
things up here we are hearing that the
live feeds are very active right now so
maybe head on over to CBS all access to
check those out maybe Omarosa james and
shannon fighting so this is what we
wanted make sure to LIKE ET on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube follow us on
twitter everywhere so you don't miss
when we do these live recounts we're
gonna do another one next Wednesday with
another special big brother again
so you don't want to miss that any final
words um just that Jason says yes Rachel
and Paul friend Jason 100% with you and
just go follow Rachel all over you can
see she's gonna post some fun stuff
today apparently um of course
at Rachel Riley V I guess on Instagram
thank you guys for watching we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]